foreign
let's go to Stephanie in Rockford
Illinois what's up Stephanie
hey how are you John I'm good how about
you
good thanks for taking my call you got
it what's up
all right so
um I have a teenage daughter uh she is
15
um and about a year ago she was
diagnosed with anxiety and depression
so the reason I'm calling is because I'm
struggling parenting with that okay
um you know how do you
know like consequences and stuff like
that because obviously her health is
more important than dishes being done
but I still don't want to raise uh you
know I still want to raise a good human
so right
um tell me the origin of the depression
anxiety where does that come from
um her dad a year and a half ago my
husband died by Suicide oh boy I'm so
sorry yeah
itself
so it's all very new
to both of us and
so is she a happy-go-lucky kid and this
was just a left turn
yeah
completely
so I'm gonna change her you got
depression you know you got grief you
got it all it's not that it's it's
um
it's not my place to comment on
diagnostics because I'm not in your
sessions and I'm not in her sessions
with whatever provider she's getting
diagnosed from but
ah
grief is hard and complex grief is hard
and I just don't believe this is
personal I just don't believe in
Diagnostics on the back end of such an
explosion in the middle of a home
there is any Behavior she has whether
she's running low or she's anxious
is absolutely normal
you know what I mean yeah
um I don't know that the diagnostic
helps any
um
so let me ask you this how have you been
I will mow for a year and a half yeah
tell me about that
um
you know she
was
um
hospitalized in January and was she
suicidal as well yeah
um no attempt but um
still suicidal so was she suicidal uh I
guess she wasn't not acutely but
I guess if she was hospitalized that
means she was pretty far down the road
right
yeah okay does she
want to be dead or does she want to stop
hurting
she wants to starting okay
and do you get the difference there
yes it's taken a while but yeah of
course of course
um can I ask you a very hard question
that I don't mean in a shaming way at
all this is just me collecting data okay
has she felt over the last year that
she's got to prop you up too
um
I don't
I don't know I don't
I would like to say no but I'm sure that
there's been times
um
for the most part though I would say no
okay
did your husband was this a surprise or
he been struggling for a long time
I'm so sorry Stephanie
two man
so
coming out of the out of the fog I'm
gonna I'm gonna just pretend here that
18 months and there's that gnawing
reality that this is real
and there's that low level
just weight that sits on you is that
still there yeah it just kind of is
um have you had moments where you
laughed and you felt guilty for laughing
yeah
have you had moments where you
like somebody makes your heart beat a
little faster and you feel guilty about
it
no okay
have you been profoundly lonely
um I was okay working on that part good
how do you feel guilty
like you should have known something or
said something or done something
absolutely yeah okay
foreign
so here's what we do coming out of
survival
is the sooner you can well number one
you can't rush grief it just is and it's
a pain it just is
it's awful and it's hard and it's right
and it's the worst
and it just is
okay
um
there's some ways to manage it and
there's some things you can do over time
so that when that fog begins to lift
that you could be you can breathe okay
but the quicker you guys you and her do
you have any other kids
no just her okay the quicker you two
recognize that
there's not ever going to be a going
back to normal that we have to change
everything
that everything is new now
that's a horrifying feeling of it's just
a period at the end of a Long messy
weep like weepy sentence
but it's also when the light starts to
come on because now you get to build
what comes next
and what I would suggest is the path out
for your daughter
is feeling like she is participating in
going towards something not trying to
survive something
okay
and what that means is you've heard me
say this a lot and
um I would love to see you try it out
that you and your daughter go to go
somewhere and spend a day or two or a
weekend
and have some sort of ceremony where you
put to bed what was
this was our life and now this is our
life and we get to construct it however
we want and here's the question we're
going to answer who are we going to be
and we're going to talk in that who are
we going to be we're going to be people
who take care of our bodies
so we're gonna go for walks every day
together
and we're not gonna eat pizza every
night like we're gonna take care of
ourselves that's who we're gonna be
we're going to be people of service
we're going to be people who think about
other people before we think of
ourselves
we're going to be people who
get stuff done so I'll do the dishes you
do this you does that make sense and out
of that we're going to give ourselves
jobs and we're going to commit to
holding each other accountable
the goal here is little wins
they'll and the Temptation is
is to say hey you got to do the dishes
she doesn't do them you get mad and that
drives her further into a hole which is
just a normal pattern that parents and
teens have this is just an accelerated
or actually it's a dampened
um a dance that's the same dance right
um
this is going to be a little bit
different this is who we are This Is How
We Do life together now and so she is
going to participate in the life of the
household she's not just going to do
crap to keep mom off her back do you see
the difference
yeah and that starts with you saying I'm
going to commit to
getting well
during the season of grief
much
your teenage daughter is going to watch
her mom for how she's supposed to act
and I know that's a lot of
responsibility on you
yeah
tried to you know just get
disgustation as much
different has she seen you be sad
yeah okay
that's a good thing by the way
giving her permission to feel sad is
okay
letting her see her mom be sad is okay
in fact that's a gift to her
now it's about finding purpose in that
home with this new life you'll are
creating together
in this conversation you'll have
it would be
where do you want to go to college to
start having that conversation
what do you think you might want to be
how could we make meaning of dads
passing away
maybe she wants to go be a psychologist
maybe she wants to go to med school
maybe she wants to be an architect who
knows what she wants to do but
let's start looking at what is tomorrow
going to look like and what are the
things we need to do right now
have you sat down and had a conversation
similar to that
um
no I mean no not
that that one comes
is very much harder than the
conversations we've had it's here's
here's why it's hard
because when
your husband died by Suicide life as you
knew it was over
and we focus a lot in our grief on the
person
and we forget or we don't even know that
everything is different
a lot of times people run out and get
remarried within three months or six
months because they're trying to get
back to normal the body's job is to get
back to homeostasis it tries it tries to
tries
and there is no homeostasis here
everything's in Ash
everything
in this conversation do we sell the
house do you want to move to a new town
do I need to get a new job like right
we're having those conversations
and she's going to play a part in it she
doesn't get the final say and I would
let her know I'm the mom so I'm gonna
make the final call
but I want to hear where your heart is
she doesn't get everything she wants but
hey how do we what are some things you
want to be who are we going to be we're
going to go to concerts we are going to
do things intentionally to bring joy
into our lives however hard it will be
and we're going to buy tickets to
concerts and we may listen to two songs
we're just gonna leave because one of us
starts crying that's okay
right yeah
how are you financially
um okay I mean obviously inflation is
not the greatest but
um yeah we're okay have you had to sell
that have you sold the house no we're
still in the house okay
have you considered selling the house
um
I'm to that point that I think I would
be able to okay
um where he died
um was by a tree and that tree just uh
fell
on a random weekend
um and I felt
like I could leave then took it took
that like before I felt like I couldn't
like I just couldn't
um there's something profound about
environment when it comes to grief
mm-hmm
um I'm not saying that everybody who has
somebody passed away has to sell their
house has to leave the state but there
is something freeing about changing the
environment
um changing quite honestly everything
some people stay in the same city and
move houses some people just control all
delete and say I'm gonna go I always
wanted I realize how precious and short
life is I always wanted to be a teacher
I'm going back to school to get my
teaching certificate or I wanted to be a
nurse I'm going to get my Nursing degree
like whatever happens
these are the moments that y'all sit
down and you have these conversations
together and here's why the conversation
with her is so important instead of you
going off and doing this by yourself and
making an announcement
because you get to model for her what
the process of thinking and feeling and
weeping and putting your foot down looks
like
you get to say I've always wanted to do
this and I never did it
and I think I'm gonna go back to school
and do it and it's going to be hard and
it's going to be scary and it's going to
be whatever
but I get to be in control of what comes
next however hard that is
and she gets to see get a picture of
what that looks like because she doesn't
have a picture of what to do if that
when Dad dies by Suicide
right she doesn't have a picture of what
how do you how do you replant after the
forest burns down and that's what you're
going to offer her and by the way you
may not have that picture either
yeah because I mean we really didn't
make any changes you know we just
continued on
without him here yeah
and even if y'all end up in a very
similar situation doing these very
similar things and she's going to the
same school and all that stuff the
exercise in and of itself is valuable
and I want you to also hear the big
picture I have not focused on her
anxiety and depression
those are particular snapshots of a
particular season of her life right now
if she's suicidal she's got to go back
to the hospital if you find out she's
going to take her own life you gotta
call 9-1-1 and do the whole thing over
again okay and there may be more of that
as a 15 year old tries to wrestle with
the overwhelming sense of of dread and
doom and hurt that she's going through
right now
and there may be something to letting
her know
um or guarantee that she's asking
herself what was so bad about me that
Dad felt he had to go
and I guarantee you've asked yourself
that question too
yep
it would really be helpful to her to let
her know that you're asking that
question as well
okay it would also be really helpful for
her to know that
Dad wasn't well Dad was sick
had nothing to do with you
I mean I've tried
so I know I know
but let her know that you're having the
same concerns inside yourself too
I'm so Stephanie I don't think I've done
that yeah I'm I I'm just heartbroken for
you I'm sorry
I'm sorry
well I appreciate hearing though that
you know her anxiety and depression May
uh you know it may be a season it may
not be I don't I don't think your
daughter's broken
I don't think she's malfunctioning
um I think her body's doing exactly what
a 15 year old body should be doing right
now when Dad dies by Suicide which is
every alarm it's got is going off to the
point that the body gets exhausted and
then it runs really low turns everything
off
I think depression and anxiety are on
the same trend line they work together
and so it's a body that tells me it's a
body trying to figure out where it is in
space
not to mention the hormones and the
growing and all the other things that
come along though just general crap of
being 15 right right
um
you put that on top of I'm completely
untethered
from everything and
um yeah you got a kid that just wants to
stop everything I just want I just want
to stop
and so let's begin to have a
conversation of what does it look like
to rebuild a life worth living in the
shadow of what we've experienced
and that shadow
is going to be as long as it's going to
be the Shadow's not going to go away but
what you're going to find over time is
that y'all are going to grow Beyond The
Shadow
Shadow will always be there
but you're gonna find that you grow Way
Beyond that shadow
it's just hard to see it right now
because everything's dark
mm-hmm
this may be a conversation that you have
with a counselor
um I think quite honestly I think you've
been thoughtful enough you've got people
in your life I think you can write this
stuff down and you can take her out for
a girls weekend
and give you all give yourself a moment
to point back to in times this is when
we went out this is when we created this
new family values this is when we
decided what our last name is going to
be that's when we decided where we're
going to live for the next year and then
we're going to figure it out after that
this we decided whether you're going to
college where I'm going to keep working
here this is where we made some some
decisions and we held those decisions
really Loosely because plans change and
grief is a terrible master
but this is when we started looking for
the light again
and this is when that little girl feels
less crazy because Mom opens up and says
hey I'm going through that too
my dad wasn't okay and it wasn't because
he didn't love you Dad loved you so much
and so for some reason he thought you
would be better off with him not here
God we know he's wrong on this side of
that choice but
we get to work together to create what
happens next
I'm so so sorry